after running the RNA seed pipeline you  will get the option to view all your  output files in the download pipeline  output files option that you see here  and here in the download folder you have  many types of expression tables first of  all there are gene expression table and  isoform expression table we provide  these expression tables in fpkm and then  raw reads now below you'll also see  various visualization options  so if you click here to see if our reads  are of good quality we can take a look  at the multi-qc report online for  quality assurance  next here you can see  a histogram with gene expression given  in the form of fpkn values and on the  top you can also see the gene expression  of the sample represented in the form of  a box plot  we can also look at other graphs and see  what they say about our samples here we  can see the overall gene expression of  our samples represented in the form of a  box plot